[Music]
okay so with that we will get going
um there is a script that i have to read
so bear with me
um as chair of the environment and
agriculture committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result
of the covenant 19 pandemic and in court
with the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe
and listen contemporarily i always mess
up that word i'm sorry
contemporary knit can
attempt me
i see it three more times i'm sorry
about that one the one word i always get
stuck on to this meeting which is
authorized pursuant
of the governor's emergency order
however in accordance to the order
i am confirming that we are a providing
public access
to the meeting by telephone with
additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic needs
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to
communicate contemporarynessly
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has
access to contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
the meeting by clicking on the following
website address
http s colon
forward slash forward slash www dot
zoom dot u s forward slash j
forward slash nine eight nine zero one
nine zero nine one two
zero or dialing one of the following
phone numbers
one three one two six
two six six seven nine nine
four one nine two nine
two zero five six zero nine
nine b providing public notice
of the necessary information for
discussing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using
zoom or telephonically this information
is printed
in the house calendar c providing a
mechanism
for the public to alert the public body
during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anyone has a problem please
call 603-271-3600
or email at hcs
ledge dot state dot
nh dot u s
d adjoining the meeting
adjoining the meeting if the public is
unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that is on
the meeting assisting us
joel anderson who is our meeting host
additional staff preventing support are
gen 4
and brad greenland
today this is an executive session on
bills referred to
this committee for interim study these
bills
are house bill 646-fn
relative to labeling sign-in signage
and restrictions on the sales and use of
b-toxic pesticides
house bill 14-18 authorizing funds
of the department of agriculture to be
used for increasing
farm energy efficiency
house bill 1422-fn
establishing a moratorium on the
issuance of permits for new landfills
or the expansion of existing landfills
for the purpose of studying
the creating of municipal waste
districts and then lastly house bill
fna establishing a value-added grant
matching fund for new hampshire
agricultural
producers copies of the interim study
bills
have been posted on the main page of
general court's website
under the hearing i'm sorry heading
quote remote meetings end quote
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the rape to know
law
i'll sit again
can you hear me cannot i'll be right
back
i believe we can hear you
would you
i think she said she would be right back
yes
yep
can you hear me yes okay great sorry
about that i've been having some audio
difficulty
so representative bixby
present and i am alone in my house
i can't hear you oh
can you hear me right now
no nope she can't hear anybody
uh sorry about that um
could you repeat that please yes i am
present and
alone in my house okay um representative
billio
i am here uh alone in my house
okay representative ellis i'm here and
alone in my house
representative richards i am
here but i am outside where i am alone
okay representative sofikidas
okay not present representative
she's here she's uh hold on one second
remember in contrast she's there she was
just muted
oh sorry uh can you hear me now i can
i'm i'm president and i'm um alone in my
house
okay great representative bolden
uh i am present and i'm alone in my
office but my
wife and child are in the house with me
and may be coming in and out
okay representative crayton i am here i
am also alone in my office but i
have my husband downstairs on a
different meeting
representative dutsy i'm president
and alone in my office
represent mcconnell president and alone
in my home office
okay uh representative murray i'm
present
and alone in my office but there are
other members elsewhere in the house
okay uh representative o'connor i am
president alone in my office
and my wife is uh downstairs
okay uh representative
um but there are people that will
probably could be walking in and out
um sporadically um but for at present i
am
completely alone representative pearl
i am present and all alone in my office
representative verville
i am uh in my office currently alone
representative aaron i am
present and in my home my husband
is upstairs in his home office on
another
okay representative bean
representative bean uh representative
bean uh could you uh press star six to
unmute yourself
okay
okay we'll give representative bean a
minute to
unmute himself uh representative furbush
not present okay represent melvin
muted hello
[Music]
okay you got me now we got you perfect
i'm home in my home by myself
okay uh represent representative
president in my home office alone
okay and representative bean
can you hear me now we can
so uh where are you i'm home my wife is
in and out
i'm home perfect excellent
did i miss anybody oh madam chair yes
thanks um yes i am present and i'm in my
office alone
okay anyone else
that i may have missed
okay so we have
19 present and one absent
great thank you
all right well with that said and the
rule call done thank you all very much
um let's let's get on with this uh
so with that said uh let's move on to
house bill 646
fn relative to labeling signage
and restrictions on the sale of
sale and use of b toxic pesticides
this is an executive session so just
like being in
our hearing room i'm going to ask for a
motion
oh shoot i know representative safakidas
has emotion
i do i just hold on i didn't know what
happened here i lost my video
we see you okay happy
yes i um i do want to make a motion
on house bill 646 f n
a i think it has on it and i move to
recommend this bill for future
legislation
thank you and do i have a second second
representative
i'm sorry who seconded that uh
representative bolyer
thank you all right
thank you both um representative safidas
would you like to speak to your motion
yes i would i am this is a very pressing
issue for our time and the decline
in the bee population and in the local
insects the native insects has been
dramatic
and many many states are working on this
subject right now to try to limit
the use of the toxic pesticides to
so that they can regrow their
environment
so that is our hope to get
on this legislative step can bring all
the different kinds of research
in so that we can craft a good bill
going forward
thank you um is there any further
um discussions madam chair this is
representative pearl
yeah madame sierra
i am not in favor of moving this bill
forward and i
for many reasons but you're going to
find a common theme with all four of the
bills coming up that
we were our caucus was concerned with
the fact that
these bills were all supposed to be put
into a study committee and
you know we'd agreed to do that we had
concerns
of of our own as well as other concerns
that were raised during the hearings on
these bills
and we didn't feel it was prudent to
move these forward without having those
questions
and and concerns answered so uh
i will not be supporting this bill to
move forward for
for that main reason that we've now not
had the opportunity to have our
questions and concerns
studied or answered and i feel it would
be just as viable to just
return this bill and bring it back next
year in its original form and
i think the committee would at that
point in time it'll be a new seated
committee and they would
take a uh you know we could look at the
bill and uh
make a decision at that point if they
wanted to work on it or
or how they wanted to proceed madam
chair thank you
rebellion pearl yes representative
o'connor yes uh just uh
two two thanks for first thing uh on the
housekeeping uh i had my hand
up so are you watching who's that joel
watching for the hand
up or we both are
okay all right i also want to agree with
uh representative pearl uh very briefly
i won't go into all the detail that we
did back in september in november of
but we do know that the population in
the state of new hampshire
has not been an issue with neon mix
but it has actually to do with the
rivero
might uh there's been studies that have
been done by
unh dr wallin fit also even uh stated
that
uh we also had presentations by
director russo and uh the gentleman i
can't think of his name off the top of
my head
that does the bee analysis uh
that indicated that the first failure of
the beehives in new hampshire is the
might followed by
new beekeepers that are inexperienced
whereas
all the ones are doing well in addition
to that their survey of last year
showed that they have found eight to ten
brand new bee
uh species within the state of uh new
hampshire
so um with that i believe that our uh
ibm the integrated management program
does an outstanding job in here uh and
as representative pearl said
uh we're supposed to receive
documentation on the e
epa uh results that were coming out
uh plus uh we had a nice handout by doc
by uh director russo
on what the state was doing to mitigate
that
and especially the issue with giving uh
full powers to the commission of what
can be accepted by pesticides and not
accepted so with that i will not be uh
supporting this bill
thank you uh thank you thank you roger
o'connor
um representative bixby you have your
hand up would you like to add
uh yes i'd like to um
a little bit of clarification in terms
of the form that this should be going
forward in i believe that um
i'm not sure if it was entirely clear
from uh what representative
akita said but um the it would
be appropriate to have this put forward
as a study committee
in the uh first term first year of next
term
because um it needs more study than we
can
before drafting the actual legislation
then we can
um then we can manage given the
constraints
of coven 19 those constraints are also
what prevented us from
dealing with it appropriately over the
summer uh
so uh i think that uh
there are there is a real problem with
uh
the with a number of pesticides in terms
of
weakening the bee population and
the current thinking among entomologists
is that
it is not a single factor that is uh
weakening bee populations but as a
combination of factors
one of the factors is that um
there are a range of pesticides that
reduce
the ability of bees to have their
natural resistance
to a range of diseases and pests and b
pests
such as the mites and such as nosema
and american foul brood there's a whole
range of
um of b diseases and
when the bee population is uh is
weakened by pesticides
they are they they have less of their
natural resistance to those
other um damaging factors
so i think that we really do need to go
forward with legislation
and i think that we need to have a
thorough study to figure out exactly how
that should be set up for new hampshire
great thank you very much jordan bixby
um so here a hand just came flying up so
here's the order that we're going to go
in
representative ellis because you're
actually holding your hand up so you're
going to go next
and then representative erin and
representative bolden you'll go next and
then within
our attendees we do have a hand raise
it's representative horrigan
because we're in an executive session
i'm not going to call on you so you can
put your hand down um so with that said
the three of you if you're ready to go
representative ellis you're next
um as i understand that you can't rely
on unh
because the people that were experts at
it have
moved on to different jobs i guess
and i'm in favor of moving this
legislation on
and not in a study committee
because uh it's just slowing it down
and we need to act a lot faster than we
are right now
[Music]
and the constituents of kaabi are really
concerned about having it moved on
thank you madam chair thank you
representative ellis thank you
i represent aaron yes thank you very
much
madam chair i just wanted to echo
what uh representative pearl and
representative o'connor had said but
um i'm i'm concerned about moving this
particular
bill along rather than
creating some new legislation because
one of the reasons why we
wanted to do work on this bill was
because we were waiting for some
updated statistics and new information
apparently through some of the testimony
that we heard
that there were some
some data that was being gathered and
we were also looking to see what had
happened
uh in places like the european union
that had banned certain pesticides and
what the effects that that would have
been
so i i don't see um i don't see the
the um uh
see that we should be moving this
particular bill along
and instead be looking at uh perhaps
in the future coming up with a better
crafted bill
thank you thank you and
um representing the bulls and then we'll
go right to them
uh thank you madam chair um i understand
what we've previously discussed about
the best
strategy for filing bills next term but
at this point
as a committee i think it would be
inappropriate to kind of get into the
weeds
by discussing what specific type of bill
should be filed next year
especially since i don't think we should
prejudice a future legislature or a
future iteration of this committee
for or against any specific bill
language so i think we should just
express our desire to see more on the
subject
and why we feel it's important and let
the future legislators decide the best
way to craft legislation to satisfy that
end and that's why i'm gonna vote to
support the
uh motion to recommend for future
legislation
great thank you president bowman um uh
christian
madam chair um i'm also going to vote in
support of recommending future
legislation
um i believe representative erin had a
great point that
um the delay has given us some time to
see
new research coming out of the european
union and elsewhere
um in fact there was a great study um
earlier this year about in
the journal of see i have it
my here i clicked away uh
where are you oh yes the journal of
agriculture ecosystems and the
environment
uh showing reduced species richness of
native bees
in fields that have been treated with
neonicotinoids elsewhere in
north america i also want to
highlight the point that this bill is
not intended to
protect only honeybee species commercial
honeybee species
but also our native bees which are more
susceptible to
accumulation in soils and and i think
more um
you know and of course where we just
have a lot less uh
research known but what it is there is
certainly in support of
of bees being very susceptible to these
sorts of pesticides
i also want to note that the original
bill that was brought for this was much
more comprehensive in terms of
addressing
all the multiple factors that we know
affects bees habitat loss
all those kinds of things and and we're
told to
make it more narrow which we've done so
um
i feel that that's been addressed
appropriately and uh
yes i will be voting to support this
building stuff
perfect thank you um okay so
representative bean
i'm not sure if you want to say anything
you don't have to if you don't want to
but because
i can't see a hand raise i just want to
make sure that you don't want to add to
this conversation
with that said is there any additional
conversation
concerns comments before we go into the
voting mode
all right so with that representative if
you are ready
we can do our roll call or vote
okay so the motion on the table is to
wrote uh
recommend for future legislation 646
fn-a representative bixby yes
representative bolio yes representative
ellis
representative ellis
you need to unmute
yes thank you representative richards
yes representative suffocatus
yes representative bolden
yes representative tien yes
representative dutzy yes
representative mcconnell yes
represent murray yes
representative o'connor new
representative pearl no represent
country
no representative virgil
no representative aaron no
representative bean
no
uh representative melvin no
represent vienne no
madam chair yes
okay
11 to 8 motion passes
all right thank you very much
okay and with that um just to recap
normally when we're in our hearing room
we would have a minority
and a majority report in this instance
the committee is putting together one
report
so um i don't need um
[Music]
we already know who's going to write
that report so it's going to be
representative
bolden so um so we're good there
so check all right moving on then
can i just clarify just a little bit
about that
it's not that uh it's not a factor of us
being
uh in our on zoom versus being in the
committee room it's a matter of this is
the way it works with
a retained bill true thank you very much
this is bixby i appreciate the
clarification that is true
at this point in the process yes
um okay so moving on
if clerk or wherever they're coming
would you be ready if we moved on to the
next
i'm ready perfect all right
i can't just look right over at you and
see what what forms are in front of you
also so all right well
um moving on then we have house bill
which is authorizing funds of the
department of agriculture to be used for
increasing farm energy efficiency
do i have a motion yes
i move that we recommend for future
legislation
and do i have a second i'll second that
represent murray thank you
all right um and with that
representative would you like to speak
to your motion
yes the um that we referred this to
interim study because
uh although we thought it was a good
idea to
improve energy efficiency and
enter small-scale energy production
on farms we thought that uh well it was
clear that the
funding mechanism using the department
of agriculture
um uh water treatment funds was
incorrect and uh we felt that
the department of agriculture was the
wrong place to
um administrate this but uh in terms of
the idea of
uh improving energy efficiency on farms
and clearly there are a number of energy
intensive things on farms like if you're
doing maple syrup
i'm sure uh then
there's a lot of energy in terms of
either using
boiling or some combination of boiling
and reverse osmosis
and any operation that requires
refrigeration obviously uses a lot of
energy
by um improving the efficiency of those
processes and by generating electricity
on site
farms could get a great advantage it
could have a great advantage
in terms of their costs so and
one of the barriers is that the
long-term savings is substantial but
getting over that initial um problem of
having the capital to
get the equipment in place is a real
challenge uh
so being able to uh have the
the state help out farms with uh funding
this sort of thing
is a really great idea um
and i think that the future legislation
should
uh should uh figure out
the best way to fund it and which um
um administrative department should be
overseeing it but i think there's a it's
a great idea and it should go forward
great thank you revlon bixby um leave
two hands that will go in order
so representative pearl and then
representative o'connor
i'm faster than he is
you're younger oh
that's true uh thank you madam chair so
uh i i would say you know for many of
the reasons that i stated
in the last bill that we had a lot of
unanswered questions and
for some of the reasons that uh
representative bixby just raised about
you know the concern about having it
funded within the
department of agriculture and especially
in the manner that it was
it just seems to me like it would be a
lot cleaner to
not recommend this bill because there's
so many different areas that don't work
well
and to just come back with a clean new
bill next year and present it
and it just seems to me like it would be
it would be a lot it would be it would
be a lot cleaner to do that and come in
with a with a bill that isn't going to
reference a bill that we know it has
some problems in it already and
and i don't think it sets it back any to
not move this bill forward and come in
with a
with one next year that hits the areas
that
you know that some of the concerns that
we had and and i think it would be
better off for the committee next term
which hopefully many of us will be back
but
for those who are they they know this
bill existed and they understand that
and those who weren't will have the
ability you know in the
to look at a nice new clean bill that's
going in a better direction
thank you representative o'connor thank
you madam chair
uh first with some of representative
bixby said
is correct but uh i still can't support
the bill
uh basically a lot of what the
representative pearl had mentioned
but i want to echo the sentiments of the
commissioner
uh this bill has two components to it
and if we could
it should be split on the commissioner
and i quote
says the department has no expertise in
the energy management
of some of the areas and this bill
should direct it
over to the department of uh initiatives
uh basically it's nutrition a new
nutrient type
bill which they special uh specialized
in the areas of manure pits etc
so with that i would recommend that any
legislators coming back for next years
to
either offer two bills to the forward
but i can't support the bill as written
uh
as per the request to the commissioner
thank you
thank you or general connor is there any
further discussion
no one's hand is up at this point
no all right well with that rather than
comfort would you like to
please call the vote sure thank you
madam chair
um so we're taking a vote on uh
recommending for future legislation
house bill 1418 representative bixby
yes representative bullio
yes representative ellis yes
representative richards
yes representative safakidas
yes represent bolden
yeah representative craigtien yes
representative dutsy yes representative
mcconnell
yes representative murray yes
representative o'connor no represent
pearl no represent country
no representative verville no
representative aaron no no represent
bean
no represent melvin
no represent the end
no motion passes 11 to 8.
well representative i didn't vote oh
madam chair you and you anticipated my
vote yes
i'm sorry
i forget to go back to the talk all the
time i apologize again
don't worry all right and with that done
motion passes
um we'll move on to the next one then so
house bill 1422
fn which is establishing a moratorium on
the issuance of permit
for new landfills or the expansion of
existing landfills for the purpose
of studying the creation or the creating
of municipal waste districts
with that may i please have a motion
i'd like to make a motion yeah remember
yes i'd like to move this legislation
forward for a future legislation
this bill for future legislation
thank you is there a second
okay i'll second two
hey i have represented bixby first
that's fine
okay okay um
would you like to speak to your motion
yeah we had a lot of uh public that
attended these meetings in support of
the bill
and um we are elected
to uh listen and represent the people so
um i don't think it's unreasonable um
i think there is um
a need uh for moratorium um
as discussed in our community hearings
and i support moving
this for future legislation thank you
thank you um our one hand up at the
moment is for representative o'connor uh
thank you madam chair
and uh i cannot also support this bill
um last year 2019
a commission from the pre a previous
bill
was established and representative evil
was the chair
representing murray and representative
o'connor
we sat in there and we had
many many meetings
a lot of stakeholders on all areas
of concern and the
response and the report coming out of
that committee
and commission developed a huge study
uh going forward and correct me if i'm
wrong representative marriage since you
were taking all the notes down there
that um this would only just confuse the
issue
and we should stay with one major uh
bill that's already out there
that's being established and i also let
representative evil know that i would
not be able to
join her on future legislation but i'd
be there for testimony
thank you mount thank you
is there any additional conversation
comments questions concerns there we go
representative pearl
you're on mute
there we go try it again i waited this
time so that representative o'connor
could be first
thank you madam chair uh again i want to
echo the same sentiment that we had a
lot of unanswered questions on this bill
and we didn't have the benefit
of of having the study committee that
was supposed to occur so
for that reason i i feel it would be
best to not move
this legislation forward and allow a
bill to come in next year from a new
sponsor
with however they would like to bring it
in thank you
thank you with that and no other hands
any
any questions comments concerns before
we move forward
no and representative contra you could
please call the
vote and so we are voting on uh
recommending for future legislation host
bill 1422-fn
representative bixby yes representative
bullio
yes representative ellis
representative ellis mute and please
yes thank you representative richards
no representative safiquitas
yes represent bolden
yes represent kratien
yes representative dutsy
yes representative mcconnell yes
the future legislative yes
representative o'connor no
representative pearl no representative
contoir
no representative verville no
representative aaron no representative
uh representative melvin no
representative no madam chair
yes okay
ten to nine motion passes
thank you very much moving on to our
last
spill of the day and of our committee
term actually
so um house bill 1557
fna establishing a value-added grant
matching fund for new hampshire
agricultural
producers may i please have a motion
yes madam chair i would like to make a
motion i would like to move
for a favorable recommendation on this
legislation to move it forward
you do i have a second i'll second that
thank you does that represent murray yes
thank you you're welcome and then
representative would you like to speak
to your motion
uh yes uh this is a fairly simple
legislation i think we decided on
interim study because there was some
concerns
about how it would be initially the fund
would be initially funded and then
ongoing
funding but it was noted by the farm
bureau which
supports this legislation that new
hampshire
is currently at a disadvantage because
we do not have this fund
we cannot apply for matching grants
so by creating this fund if we can
figure out the appropriate mechanisms
we would put new hampshire on a level
playing field with other states
thank you is there any further
discussion
yes representative pearl just trying to
give representative
o'connor the opportunity to jump in
again
uh ontario thank you again the i
i have concerns that there were
questions raised on this bill
in committee especially funding
questions and going into the
tight budgeting year that we're going to
be going into next year i just think it
would prudent
not to recommend this to move forward
and to allow for a bill to be
presented by a representative in the
fall if they felt this was a worthwhile
endeavor to do so thank you thank you
any further discussion questions
comments concerns
yes ma'am champ i can't find my hand
uh just a concerto representative pearl
uh
if the commissioner deems that this
could be an important area
then let him add it into the uh budget
and uh go through the budget process
that would be the easiest way to do it
thank you madam chair
thank you did you have yes a question
yeah
i just wanted to make a a comment i
think
we could establish this um uh fund
with few dollars i don't think it needs
to be ten thousand twenty thousand
i'm not quite sure but i think if we
have something set aside
uh whether it be a thousand or you know
500 i think that would establish the
fund and then we could
you know uh go uh seeking uh
grants um to help our farmers
all right okay
thank you um any other discussions
common thoughts concerns
we'll move on with
that said representative dutsy i'm sorry
remember if you would like to uh call
for the vote
okay uh we're voting on
recommending for future legislation
house bill 1557
fna representative bixby yes
representative bolio yes representative
ellis
representative ellis
there you go can you representative
ellis yes
thank you representative richards yes
representative safikidis yes
representative bolden
yes representative craitienne yes
representative dutsy yes representative
mcconnell
yes represent murray yes
representative o'connor no
representative pearl
no representative contoir no
representative verville
no representative aaron no
represent bean
no uh represent melvin
no represent vienne
no all right madam chair
yes okay 11
8. motion passes
thank you very much also i want to thank
you all
for our first and last digital gathering
um it's been wonderful working with all
of you
i'm glad that some of you are not
returning next year like representative
o'connor is not running again
um but i um and i i do want to thank
him he he was huge as you all probably
know he was chair
before me um and so i relied a lot on
him
uh to learn the role and so um
and passing sticky notes between us and
um our seats
so i just want to say thank you very
much for your help and
you will be missed in this committee um
next year and
future years don't give up on secrets
well whoever says next you know in the
front again next year
will have to pass notes back and forth
it's all good
rather than pearl and i did it too when
when you're out so
don't worry um uh with that
said president of murray your hand is
raised
yeah i just wanted to echo the
sentiments of the chair uh
representative
connor you're going to be greatly missed
and i thank you for
all of the work that you've done
alongside of myself and on behalf of the
committee so i wanted to say thank you
and i wish you good health in the future
thank you um
representative pearl yes thank you madam
chair
i want to thank you too and
representative bixby
and the whole committee uh you know we
are looked at
as one of the few by partisan committees
in the house and we all worked very well
together
and uh and i appreciate uh
the uh the opportunities you gave me to
step in and work with you and
representative bixby
in in representative o'connor's absence
there for a while and
i think we had a very smooth transition
and i think the committee
did a very fine job we are you know
we're in agreement on most all bills
and i appreciate the professionalism
from from everyone on the committee and
look forward to uh hopefully many of us
returning next year to continue the good
work
yeah and thank you represent
oh yeah hold on one second reverend
o'connor uh representative bixby has his
hand up
yeah so i'd like to echo that sentiment
um
i think that we did a really good job of
amending a lot of legislation that came
to us
and making it putting into much better
shape and
i am very disappointed that
the pandemic has put a lot of that
legislation on hold
and i look forward to bringing it back
next term
and i think i hope we can move it
through very swiftly since we've done a
lot of the hard work already and i
i'd like to thank all the members of the
committee uh
to uh for the
thoughtful work that you've done um i'd
also like to specifically thank uh john
o'connor because he has been
uh great to work with since i uh first
joined the committee
in 2013 and
uh it's been just a real pleasure
working with you
and um we're going to miss you
my turn after that comment yes please
and then we'll go to representatives
okay well thank you very much all uh i
will miss uh
being up there uh i do want to thank uh
mr bix representative bixby uh one of
the key things that we did as a group
after many many many years got 501
through an omnibus bill that was the
cost of care that got capped at two
million dollars
uh we still have a commission on that
that i'll be running cheer
uh hopefully around the first of october
we set that up with
joel but there were many bills that we
all agreed upon that
went into an army bus bill and i think
that representative bixby just brought
up
those need to be picked up by whoever
wins and
bring them back next year because
they're ready to go
and they were good bills so there's a
lot that's you know
that can come out of this committee that
can't be forgotten so again i thank you
all and
hopefully i'll be up to every once in a
while to testify if needed
thank you mom um that'd be fun
representation
i just want to thank uh representative
um leader
um o'connor for everything that he's
done since i've been elected he
um he was a great chairman and he made
us all feel welcome
and he his knowledge base is
just incredible and um
i will miss that the most because he
knows what's going on
at the city level and at the municipal
level
he knows everything and we're gonna miss
that sorely
but he his decorum and grace i think are
the things that i'll miss the most and i
i wish you all the best john thank you
representative aaron yes i i also want
to echo those sentiments and as a
first-year first-termer whatever
legislator of course this is all
new to me and i had to learn a lot and
i've got to say
that i want to thank you very much
representative gore
chairman gord and representative
o'connor
for your leadership and your
encouragement
and your support for not only me but
everybody on the committee
um this was a wonderful experience to
work on this committee this year with
everybody
i especially appreciate
the sensible discussions that we've had
the sharing of ideas the
the fact that we worked hard and
diligently on many of these pieces of
legislation
and we came out with some really good
bills which
was a shame that um some of them didn't
make it through
and hopefully we'll be able to deal with
them next time
with for whoever is here next year
um i think that
this is really a great group of people i
enjoyed working with
all of you and um i think
we should really really be proud of the
work that we've done together
so um i want to thank you all and in
particular of course we're going to miss
representative o'connor i wish him all
the best
and and continued good health
green yes richard
i'm not sure there's a motion that we
can make
but in listening to this it feels like
the rest of the house
should hear the way this committee works
and talks about each other
it's really a pleasure to listen
to all of that
as we always said we leave the d and the
r at the door
all right well after all that warm
fuzzies i hope you all have a wonderful
day
and if you should be anything obviously
feel free to reach out to me
or representative bixby or
representative o'connor or represent
pearl
or joel so with that you all have a
great day
great see you all yeah be careful thank
you thank you madame
john